Did you ever hear the tragedy of Darth
Plagueis the wise
welcome back everyone it's Charlie!
this is going to be my full Star
Wars Episode nine rise of Skywalker
review video if you're new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
easter-egg videos there's a whole bunch
of Mandalorian stuff coming up too so
because this is meant to be my full
review I'll say it careful for spoilers
from Star Wars rise of Skywalker because
we'll be talking about everything every
aspect of the movie so it needs to be
said yes the movie does feel like a bit
of a hot mess highlight reel of a reddit
wishlist of Easter eggs and references
like they weren't quite sure how they
wanted to end things and JJ Abrams came
in really late they didn't have a lot of
time to finish the script so they said
what can we give fans that they will
hate the least like there are a number
of choices we can make based on what's
been set up in the trilogy so far we
need to answer all these questions what
are the choices that we can make that
people will hate the least so we'll do
that so even though there were a couple
things that I think worked really well I
think most of the issues with the film
come from the fact that it feels like a
Franken film that sort of cobbled
together based on movies that don't
really exist an unproduced remake of the
last Jedi that the Star Wars people feel
like fans wanted their number of
character beats like say for Luke
Skywalker that directly contradict what
he was doing during last Jedi so it's
very clear that a lot of the things that
they did during rise of Skywalker are
meant to address things that they felt
people were upset about during last Jedi
in the fact that they brought Palpatine
back physically feels like a last minute
addition like that wasn't originally
part of their plans for the movie so
there are a couple of things that they
do with force lore and Sith Lord that
seemingly contradict the earlier films I
will address that stuff too the actors
do try to do their best with the
material but most of the time there
aren't any real conversations happening
between people because a lot of the
movie feels like a glorified fetch quest
like you would see in a video game like
a lot of you been playing fallen order
for the last couple of weeks it's a
great video game but that genre is meant
to be that way by design movies aren't
meant to be glorified fetch quests so a
lot of times when characters are talking
to each other the dialogue that they
have is
just there to set up something else
another character needs to say so they
can turn round have their big moment the
camera zooms in they say something
dramatic that then drives the characters
to the next step of their fetch quest so
the movie comes off a lot like a video
game in that way a video game with
amazing huge cutscenes like I said JJ
Abrams was pretty honest about the fact
that he was brought on really late in
the process and I think that contributed
to a lot of their development problems
originally Colin Trevorrow had a version
of the movie he was going to do he was
fired seemingly because the version of
the movie that he was going to do wasn't
something that they were really happy
about we'll never know fully what that
was going to be we've got little bits
and pieces of it so Abrams was brought
in to help them make their release date
otherwise I think if there would have
been any other director they would have
delayed the movie for another year there
are a lot of things during the movie
that do contradict earlier parts of the
can in the earlier films I also just saw
recently that the Lucasfilm story group
that are sort of the keepers of the
Canon in help people and film makers
when they're making this stuff so that
it makes sense with the other stuff
that's come before were not involved
with the making of this movie so that
was not a big surprise remember that
moment during force awakens where Han
Solo says to Finn that's not the way the
force works so I feel like a lot of the
minor missteps could have been avoided
had they brought in at least a couple of
these people whose job it is to remember
everything in every detail about Star
Wars so that they don't wind up stepping
on the toes of the movies that have come
before really good example is at the end
of the film where Palpatine says I am
all of the Sith now wait a minute all
the force spirits live within you is
that a real thing
that doesn't sound like the way the
force works first off technically the
ability to become a force spirit is
something that only highly trained Jedi
Masters can learn it isn't something
that every Jedi gets to do I think
there's a way to explain kylo Ren or Ben
solos ending at the end of the film and
why he becomes a fourth spirit but I'll
get into a lot of those minor details
and plot twists when I do my top 10
video because I feel like a lot of Star
Wars fans will be scratching their heads
in visible confusion during various
parts of the film but while there is a
lot of stuff that you can nitpick in
this movie a few things that I think
worked really well or all the scenes
with kylo Ren andhraite together when
they're just doing either they're for
Skype sessions or they're fighting each
other physically having their lightsaber
battles or
just working through their emotions
together helping each other out right
teaming up together all that stuff
worked for me I know there are a lot of
questions about the ending specifically
because the last 20 or so minutes gets
really crazy but while the movie as a
whole feels like a rushed mess I feel
like JJ Abrams came in late in the game
like he said saw the script as it was
and then saw a couple things that were
already working really well like kylo
Ren and Rey's scenes that they shared
together and decided to focus most of
his attention on getting that stuff
right I liked all the force dyad stuff
I'll get technical about how that works
this weekend when I do more explainer
videos but they're meant to be two
halves of one force being which is why
they're connected across space the way
they are and why his spirit becomes part
of her at the end of the movie two
halves a one person being United inside
Rey becoming whole inside her so she
metaphorically and literally carries him
on with herself which I think by their
logic is also meant to kind of inform
why she chooses the Skywalker name at
the end of the film the other reason for
that I think also is meant to be because
she feels like Luke and Leia are the
parents that she never had even though
like I said this movie is based on a
sequel that didn't happen like they
don't clearly set any of that stuff up
during last Jedi they're the two main
leads of the whole trilogy though so it
makes sense that Abrams would want to at
least get their story and their scenes
right during the movie
and I feel like most of their stuff does
work it's a lot of the other stuff that
I have issues with some of their arc
does feel like it was made up on the fly
post last Jedi like Abrams always wanted
Redemption for kylo Ren of sorts then
giving him the honorable death as a Jedi
like Darth Vader dying as Anakin
Skywalker and Return of the Jedi
remember JJ Abrams really likes to
repeat beats of the original trilogy I
was fine with the ending that they gave
that character Adam driver's performance
throughout this new trilogy has been
great and even though I don't think that
they originally planned on bringing
Emperor Palpatine back I do think there
was some loose plan to tie Ray's origin
to either Palpatine or someone really
evil and she was always going to have to
learn the lesson that where you come
from doesn't matter what matters is who
you choose to be all three of the new
films kind of feel like they're fighting
each other for dominance but I think the
overall message that they were trying to
go for with the new films is that it
doesn't matter if you
are born into a legacy of evil you can
choose to be a good person you can
choose your family it doesn't matter
what family you were born into but
that's kind of where I think the newer
films fall down on a thematic level is
that they sort of lack the overall
cohesion that the George Lucas trilogies
have the fall and rise of Anakin
Skywalker I know there are a lot of
questions about how the ending of this
movie with Palpatine coming back and
raised seemingly defeating him for good
seemed to contradict some of Anakin
Skywalker story in the original movies
it does a little bit but I think that's
a product of their last-minute decision
to physically bring Palpatine back like
I said I think that they originally
intended for Rey to be tied to Palpatine
in some way in his Specter would loom
over the events of the new trilogy but I
don't think they meant to make it as
literal as they did originally I think
originally JJ Abrams plan was to make
Snoke the new emperor figure of the new
trilogy and in the third movie kylo Ren
still comes back to the light helps r8
to feed him and then dies his honorable
Jedi Death the powers that be at
Lucasfilm kind of wanted to give each
filmmaker because Colin Trevorrow
originally was going to be directing the
third film so it was going to be three
different directors for three different
new films in the trilogy and they wanted
to give them as much creative power as
they could over each of their own
individual movies so you wind up with
three very different films so I really
do feel like with Star Wars needs is
either a Kevin Feige like figure who's a
little more involved in what the story
is going to be having a better plan when
they start out or just letting one
person do each of the films in a new
trilogy which is why you may have heard
Lucasfilm is sort of backing off the
idea of trilogies for the next group of
films there'll always be more Star Wars
films but I think now they're going to take
it one movie at a time and if one does
well they'll be open to doing a trilogy
with whatever those new characters end
up being despite some of the issues I
feel like some of the things that work
really well during the film are the
music John Williams has always been
fantastic with what he does for each of
the movies he's on point during rise of
Skywalker
he even has a great cameo during the
film - I think some of the stuff that
they did with Leia work real well it's
pretty cleared that they brought in
Harrison Ford at the last minute because
it was supposed to be Leia on the Death
Star that was bringing Ben's solo back
from kylo Ren the reason that he turned
back into Ben solo but because she
passed away they had to bring in
Harrison Ford like they call him a look
we really need this scene where he comes
back to the light and it needs
be one of his parents you're the only
one that's available can you please come
do this for a couple minutes
I've already talked about the stuff with
kylo Ren and Rey together Adam driver
being fantastic Daisy Ridley does what
she can with the script like I said the
script is one of the weak points of the
film when she and Adam driver are
together that's when she really shines
during the movie The Emperor's
performance is also great too even if
some of the scenes that they gave him in
the script contradict earlier parts of
the franchise talking about the very end
of the film specifically where she
buries the lightsabers on the large
moisture farm on Tatooine I think this
scene was more for the fans than it was
a logical choice for her character like
they wanted to say yes technically there
aren't any living Skywalker's left but
Ben's solos part Skywalker and his life
force now lives on inside Rey and those
original characters are so important we
want to show how important they are by
making them so important to Rey that she
chooses to take their name and carry
their legacy forward there's the Ben
solo reason for picking the Skywalker
name that she has but also I think the
idea that the force ghost of Luke and
Leia show up at the end because within
the script at least whether or not you
believe it she felt like they were the
parents that she never had like I said
though they didn't really set that up at
all during last Jedi or even during
force awakens so it's a bit of a
head-scratcher moment like okay I think
I see what they were going for but it
doesn't quite land the way that it would
had they set it up properly so even
though people are sensationalizing a lot
of their reviews and the way they talk
about the film I feel like it's just
okay and that's it but breaking my
favorite Star Wars movies from favorite
to least favorite I'm just going to include
twelve here the live-action stuff not
the animated Clone Wars movie we start
at the top with Empire Strikes Back then
a new hope return to the Jedi rogue one
Revenge of the Sith force awakens rise
of Skywalker last Jedi because it's a
well made movie but canonically just
doesn't sit well with a lot of fans then
attack of the clones Phantom Menace the
holiday special and then at the bottom
is solo because the holiday special was
made knowing that they were making
something bad intentionally just to sell
toys it's meant to be this big
advertisement they were trying to make
some sort of Shakespearean masterpiece
but everyone let me know what is your
new ranking of your favorite Star Wars
films after seeing Rise of Skywalker you
don't have to rank them all together you
can just do the 9 saga films but what's
happening next is I will do a top 10
video in a video specifically for the
ending explaining some of the canonical
changes that they make there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs I'll be doing more
Mandalorian videos but if you have any
specific videos or big questions you
want me to answer in those videos just
let me know in the comments everyone
click here for my new video for the
Mandalorians set up in the finale and
then click here for my full
Mandalorian episode 7 video thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome
I have spoken.